hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten welt ich möchte euch heute ein
schönes rezept video zeigen aber
eigentlich kein rezept sondern eher eine
anleitung der muttertag steht ihr bald
voller tür und meine mama liebt blumen
überall ist deswegen habe ich mir
gedacht was ihr heute etwas blumig ist
ich habe vor kurzem schon mal diese
jahrzehnten cupcakes gemacht und möchte
heute jetzt zeigen wie man aus cupcakes
sondern schönen blumenstrauß machen kann
als praktischen blumenstrauß thema
später wieder aufessen kann meine mama
kriegt immer ganz viele blumen geschenkt
aber ich finde es aber ganz schlimm wenn
man blumen hat dem abschneiden muss ich
meine wir haben auch ab und zu welt im
hintergrund stehen auch das video weil
es im hübsch aussieht aber ich finde
immer schöner wenn man blumentopf nimmt
oder so wie heute eben blume thema essen
kann und ich habe jetzt bereits schon
ein paar cupcakes vorgebacken das sind
meine buttermilch cupcakes video das
rezept dazu gibt es in meinem video mit
den jahrzehnten kaputt und ich aber auch
schon meine buttercreme vorbereitet da
bekommt ihr auch das rezept in dem
anderen video und es braucht ihr einfach
noch aus dem bastelladen ein paar tools
ein paar werkzeuge und zwar habe ich
jetzt hier bereits die sowas gerichtet
kurator einkaufe und zwar habe ich jetzt
hier verschiedene weisen die sind auch
verschicken groß und ziemlich schwer
mich jetzt heute für eine zu entscheiden
und dafür braucht ihr noch so eine
styropor ball und der muss halt von der
größe her passen also ich hab jetzt den
ich habe auch noch eine größere und ich
habe mich jetzt heute für die vase
entschieden und der styropor muss halt
rein passen
er ist ein bisschen zu klein aber ich
helfe da gleich mit bischen reis nach
also der ball muss man praktisch so zur
hälfte raus stehen denn das wird ein
praktisch das grundgerüst und da kann
man dann die cupcakes drumherum stecken
das mache ich gleich die räume ich jetzt
schnell weg dann brauche ich eine hohe
preis wie gesagt ich fühle ich dann
unten rein damit der ball einfach hoch
steht
hier brauche ich
zahnstocher ich habe zuletzt schnitt mit
der kamera mit und hier noch mit
lebensmittelfarbe rosa und etwas
transparentpapier das braucht man jetzt
alles ja ich würde sagen ich starte
jetzt einfach direkt und bereitet schon
mal hier
die vase top hier übrigens noch mit dem
spritzbeutel etwas buttercreme mit der
sprit schule im ident auch die
hyazinthen gespritzt habe sind die mache
ich hier auch nochmal mit rein und jetzt
ist das ganze jahr und ausgewaschen und
ich mache jetzt den reis rein und später
wenn meine mama die capex dann auf
gegessen hat kann sie den reis einfach
benutzer in kann türkische reichstag
machen ganz einfach deswegen austausche
und es stecke ich jetzt hier einfach
rein und ihr seht der ball cook die zur
hälfte aus
und jetzt habe ich hier die zahnstocher
und braucht jetzt prokopic immer zwei
zahnstocher jetzt fange ich mal hier an
und steckt dies wird hat einfach ein
besserer halt daran nehme ich jetzt eine
schönere kg christin tiefer rein und
steckt den cupcakes erstmal rein so und
es muss jetzt rund herum machen also ihr
müsst halt selber form abschätzen wie
viele cupcakes salz aus rom passen was
ich jetzt hier sehen ist dieser übergang
das ist ein bisschen blöd aber ich setze
es einfach so an
dann kann ich das glaube ich ein
bisschen umgehen
und es muss man auf jeden fall so machen
dass man erst mal drauf steckt und
daneben bespritzt weil ansonsten würde
er ständig an den muffin dran kommen und
den ganzen störe mich jetzt noch nie
zahnstocher hier oben
jetzt habe ich die erste reihe fertig
und jetzt muss ich hier oben noch füllen
ich lege mir das jetzt erst mal drauf
ich denke da passen jetzt noch zu drei
drauf genau und mehr zwischenräume sind
es gar nicht schlimm
die füllen wir nämlich später dann mit
dem transparentpapier und da mache ich
jetzt aber so dass ich den zahnstocher
bisschen höher und steckt die muffins
auch nicht ganz drauf so dass es eben
schön rund gleich aussieht
jetzt habe ich das grundgerüst fertig
man kann es vielleicht schon erahnen
und jetzt lass ich das einfach kurz
stehen wobei ich ja schon hier die eine
creme fertig habe mit den jahrzehnten
und die bespritzte ich jetzt einfach da
nehme ich mir jetzt einfach ein paar und
macht es hier kurz also bei denen ich es
so ich habe vorne ist ohne chile sieht
aus wie eine sieht aus wie so eine stand
alone uhr ist sie eben nach innen
geschlossen und jetzt spritze ich hier
einfach die blüten drauf da ist auch
wichtig dass die butter kleben nicht zu
weich ist denn sonst läuft euch das hier
gleich runter
und jetzt nehme ich einfach irgendwo
noch einen cupcake und macht so etwa
drei bis vier stück
jetzt kann ich das ganz kurz zur seite
stellen und nehme jetzt hier meine weiße
buttercreme und färbt die eine jetzt
roten die andere rosa
hatte ich nicht rot in rosa gesamtes
geld ja ich bin mit farbe blinder du
auch nicht sondern ich habe jetzt
einfach oben steht
weil das geld wahrscheinlich besser
aussieht sieht irgendwie bisschen
sommerliche aus aber das in acrylfarben
die kann schnitt benutzen
das stelle mir jetzt ganz im kühlschrank
also ich hab auch schon das rot im
kühlschrank
vielen dank
und ich kann jetzt hier schon mal meine
spritzbeutel vorbereiten und zwar
nämlich wieder ein weg spritzbeutel und
diesmal nehme ich jetzt fürs roth die
stern schule
das ist eine ganz große sie hat 14
millimeter im durchmesser und ich nehme
seine rosen thüle ist dass uns am einen
ende spitzen am andere er rund und die
zwei nehme ich jetzt auch noch
verschiedene blumen formen
jetzt beginne ich zuerst mit der
rosenschule also mit den rosen die ich
gleich spritze die sind das sind die
einfachen blüten die man spritzen kann
denn man muss wirklich nur im kreis
spritzen
ich habe einfach gesagt nur oben zu
zweifeln
und jetzt einfach irgendwo beginnen in
der mitte und bis zum rand spritzen und
dann aufhören da mache ich jetzt auch so
ein paar
und die restlichen drei hebe ich mir
jetzt auch für die gelbe krieg
und hier starte ich jetzt oben und zwar
halte ich jetzt die töne immer so dass
oben die spitze und unten die rundung
ist und da startet man jetzt außen und
wir spritzen jetzt einzelne blüten
blätter ringsherum
ich stelle jetzt die cupcakes mit der
base zusammen für etwa fünf minuten in
den kühlschrank damit die creme fest
wird denn dann kann ich sie erst fertig
machen ansonsten würde ich jetzt die
blüten alle wieder zerstören beim
ausfüllen mit dem transparentpapier das
mache ich jetzt kurz räume hier auch
noch schnell auf uns sehen wir uns
gleich wieder beim fertigstellen
meine capex ist schön kalt und erst
recht schnell arbeiten vor allem bei uns
ist viel sonne meine wohnung ist
ziemlich warm und je länger ihr die
draußen hat und so schneller gehen sie
kaputt
jetzt machen wir hier noch die
hässlichen löcher weg und zwar mit dem
transparentpapier das habe ich mir schon
zurecht geschnitten
ich hab's nicht abgemessen aber schleife
10 auf 10 und jetzt nehmen
das ist einfach in die hand und stürzte
so über euren finger man könnte das hier
reinstecken ein bisschen hellgrün vittel
dunkelgrün ganz normale
transparentpapier fischerstube holt muss
sagen dass das auf die baskenland und so
kann man eben diese löcher stopfen
und jetzt zum schluss setzte ich einfach
noch ein paar schmetterlinge darauf das
muss man natürlich nicht machen aber ich
denke es gibt dem ganzen noch den
letzten schliff
jährige aus dem kunst ist der auf- oder
freut sich natürlich freut sich mama
liebt blumen und sowas hat es
wahrscheinlich noch nie gesehen
wahrscheinlich
beim transport müssen aufpassen dass der
transportweg schnitt zu lange geht das
die ebene schmelzen oder in ebenthal
kühlelemente mails oder müssten auf
jeden fall aufpassen dass er jetzt an
die blume drankommt denn die sind ja
trotzdem empfindlich ich mach jetzt aber
eine zu viele weil ich finde dass wir
zum studie zufolge nehmen wir jetzt noch
und wenn ihr das nachmachen wollt müsst
euch einfach ein paar muffins schnappen
bisschen buttercreme und spritzbeutel
eine vase und eine styropor kugel und
dann könnte das nachmachen natürlich ist
ein bisschen knifflig also ich würde das
jetzt nicht als einfach bezeichnet weil
er müsste halt die muffins gut befestigt
ist die buttercreme schön kalt haben
oder ziemlich kühl und es eben auch
relativ schnell machen uns zügig machen
aber ich denke ja mit bisschen übung
klappt es auf jeden fall und ihr können
ihr könnt die rezepte gerne nachlesen
auf salehs blog.de da stelle ich nämlich
dass muffins rezept ein und die
buttercreme wobei ich das ja schon bei
meinen jahrzehnten cupcakes sind drin
habe und ich denke dass ich eine coole
idee mama freut sich jetzt und ich
schenk dir das dann zum als auch heute
schnitt muttertag bei uns aber ich denke
das ist einfach so weil ich liebe meine
mama jeden tag nächsten mal wieder was
hat das alles kostet wird amin überlegst
stimmt also
das wird gekocht haben alles das weiß
ich er hat glaubt ihr euren trassen ich
meinen job hat man vielleicht auch
daheim
okay die styroporkugeln allen euro 30
zimmer bei dem geschenk weg für unter
zehn euro
der ltv wir haben hier nicht zwölf
muffins wenn man weniger und die
prototypisch auch nicht woher die
lebensmittel sind nicht teuer
auf jeden fall ist ein geschenk für
unter zehn euro finde ich kann echt gut
verschenken
und außerdem ich selbst noch mit viel
liebe und schmeckt auch gut ohne sich
kein staubfänger band die macht in szene
danach direkt verknüpft finde ich mal
cool also bis zum nächsten mal